eight years ago you two were citadel's
top spies but we were double crossed by
one of our own and your memories were
erased
I brought you here because I need your
help I coached Little League
there's my guy
my favorite line in this is when you
have to say Mason Kane tops by hot stuff
and I'm sure as a Scott it probably made
you blush because you're so
self-deprecating yeah that was not easy
so what I'd love for you do is to name
each other so you so it'd be like
Priyanka Chopra top actress and then
what would be her sort of Catchphrase or
what how would you name priyankan how
would you name Richard gosh this is
really good I know because I'm like I'm
like she's an awesome background that's
it that's been awesome that's awesome
thank you awesome
Richard Madden tops by
sexy stuff
um and then speaking of which the show
very much I think as much as this is
action it's epic it hinges on this
incredible tension between the two of
you it's almost like as an audience
member am I going to kiss this person or
kill this person and there's so many
twists and turns you don't know how did
the two of you sort of create that
tension in those moments as actors I'm
sure it's not easy to do that it's not
but I think you know we understand the
assignment and that's the joy of these
two characters is like every time they
come together they have this weird
connection they're drawn to each other
it's magnetic they can't explain it even
if they don't want it they're drawn to
each other it's that really annoying
amazing thing which you can't tell if
you want to kill someone or if you want
to you know sleep with them or be with
them but that's fine as actors we always
try to lean into that we always try to
find what the obstacle is because it's
the obstacle that makes the scene a lot
more fun
um and we always dug into that whenever
we had our scenes together yeah it would
be very hard as spies to have a healthy
relationship what would be your spy
relationship advice don't be in one
don't be yourself don't be a spy don't
be a spy
that's why we work well together
hey you finish each other
I love it I love it opening scene is the
prettiest train I've ever seen in my
life no so gorgeous and you have nailed
the slow-mo it's like the quintessential
when you're growing up you always wish
you could do that slow-mo shot that you
see in movies and I feel like that is
the shot it's like a classic tips for
nailing the slo-mo kind of
walk don't walk in slo-mo
people forget about that whenever like
even on your phone when you're like oh
I'm gonna do a slow motion walk they
start walking slower but you actually
need to walk faster than you need to
because then
um if you walk faster than you normally
would then the slo-mo hits in the right
places so slightly faster this is a good
tip for life for Instagram yes I love it
and then for you there's a seam there's
nice knife catching scene for both of
you but I did a beer commercial one time
and I had to catch a bottle and just
going like that it was a fake bottle
they put it in post I couldn't get at 20
takes later it was so unnatural so the
knife sort of catching thing how did you
nail that one
I just did this
did this I know you caught it yeah
these things
um he's hot stuff yeah no I don't think
they were going to trust Stanley said
she's to throw a knife at me so they're
like you to catch it I need to catch it
and it's not a chance of that so we rely
on VFX yeah
I know you said in another interview
that this show you feel like a piece of
your soul is with the show
can you sort of describe why I mean this
is such an epic undertaking the fact
that this is a flagship Series right and
it's going to have so many iterations in
so many cities why did you say that like
was it the grueling nature of it it just
it seems like even in the first three
episodes for me it feels like the
investment in the show has been
long you know when you when you do a
movie it's like 90 days you know you're
you're done with a character
um TV any long-form entertainment anyway
is hard and then you live with your
characters for a long time we shot this
over a year and a half we shot it during
2021 which was like you know Prime covid
um we shot it in London Atlanta
um and it was just a tough shoot it was
physically demanding emotionally
demanding for me I just so I felt like
the commitment to it that it required
from me like I had to leave a piece of
me behind to be able to get up every day
and go in and deliver and there was such
a sense of accomplishment when we
finished the show like I I was like and
then when you watch it the first time
you're like okay that's why we did it
yeah it's pretty cool anything to add
it's so it's just epic it's just
incredibly epic I mean I'm thinking of I
don't even know I heard something about
a submarine and I don't even seen that
but you're skiing seeing where it was or
skiing and it was skiing there as a
submarine the submarine stuff is really
cool you're going to see that later
um but it's huge it's just such a
massive scale
so I'm asking everybody today in the
show your memory is wiped but you dream
about Priyanka which is the most
relatable thing I've ever heard because
I dreamed about you last night I don't
know why but I did
your memories were erased from your
careers okay
which actor or actress that you worked
with you think you would dream about
like today yeah today I'll only dream of
matter yeah or maybe Stanley Tucci or
Joe because we've only seen each other's
faces in this junket for the and we're
only going to see each other's faces for
the next couple of years years so I
think there's no way I could erase
Richard from my well from my memories
it's been a couple years season two I
think has been renewed but if you were
going to Moonlight on one of the other
shows in one of the other cities which
ones are you choosing
um I mean I'd love to I'd love to go
through Italy with the show yeah I mean
I really would love to go to Tuscany
that would be nice I don't mind Goa
either I want to take you to Goa you'd
love it
um between both shows there are places
we would love our characters to go you
told me to trust you why would you trust
me I'm exceedingly untrustworthy I'm a
spy so I'm gonna ask you Stanley Tucci
top actor what's your catchphrase my
catchphrase yeah what would be your sort
of Mo how you would describe yourself
how I would describe myself yes I'm
pretty
good oh great to get things going
other than I had the russos do it what
did they say they call themselves Hot
Stuff number one
I think they kept it more low-key yeah
yeah yeah I I hot stuff I'm not gonna
say hot stuff
um I would say um
conflicted
this
[Laughter]
the show has so many twists and turns
I'm wondering for you as an as an actor
did you read the entire thing did you go
episode to episode do you like to kind
of know the whole thing to shape your
your The Arc of your character or do you
like to be sort of more kept in the dark
but we were talking oh no no I have to
know as much as possible oh yeah it's
incredibly helpful I have done things
where they're sort of releasing bits and
pieces as you're shooting and you're
like can I please
have the next script can I please I mean
I'll often ask for just a sort of
overall uh synopsis of what's going to
happen you know through the six or ten
or whatever episodes because it's really
helpful it informs how you behave in
every scene yeah um not having that
knowledge you nothing can really be
specific was he snarky as snarky on the
page he is delightfully snarky as he is
yeah he was and then we you know
amped it up really yeah that was your
choice or that was sort of collectors
yeah a collective thing yeah uh the
dinner table scene with you and the
great Leslie man oh my God she's amazing
so wonderful I wish she was here today
me too let's talk about her behind her
back tell me how amazing she was she was
amazing yeah amazing I'd always admired
her
um and then you know getting to work
with her even though it was just that
one scene really we had together and we
were barely you know we were quite a
distance away from each other uh it's it
was very impressive does it change
things when you're further away the
dynamic between you know like the
physicality of it because you are sort
of further away just like in real life
right the farther away you are the
harder it is to communicate with you in
the series Richard's character loses his
memory but he's still dreaming about
priyanka's character or something about
it
if you lost your memory of your career
which actor or actress that you've
worked with do you think you would dream
about I probably dream about Meryl
Streep yeah I needed to take a pause
after you said that just have a moment
of silence because we love her so much
yeah she was influential to me
when I was you were only like 11 years
apart or something uh but she was very
influential to me when I first you know
when watching movies and seeing her in
the theater
um and then once I got to know her and
worked with her she was even more
influential you're all in with the
russos the electric State you're also in
I know what is it about the russos that
have been has been unique to you
as an actor in the way they work well I
said to them when we were working on the
electric state after we had done
you know reshoots on Citadel I said why
didn't I've been doing this for 40 years
how come I didn't meet you earlier
because really nothing this is wonderful
they're wonderful they're really smart
they're really nice
um they are
incredibly efficient
I mean their efficiency is staggering
um there are two other people that I've
worked with who have this kind of
efficiency one was Steven Spielberg and
the other was Robert zemeckis where
they're they know like they know exactly
what they're doing and when
and it's not that they're without the
ability to collaborate they're
incredibly collaborative they have a
real vision for the piece they have a
real understanding of the technical
aspects of film yeah particularly
filmmaking nowadays
but they also have a sensitivity to
human behavior and emotion and what an
actor will need but like what a
character needs but also what an actor
might need they're amazing which is
interesting that they did Marvel but
that's the thing about endgame and
infinity where the people love is
there's a Humanity to it I mean when you
see
when you see and I know a lot of those
actors you know and you see those
performances and they're really great
like it's really quite touching
you know in the scope of this huge
Whatever It Is Well this huge whatever
it is such an ambitious show yeah the
fact that this is a flagship show yeah
what they're doing has never been done
before where they're going to have these
spin-offs in different cities in
different languages is that something
that appealed to you as an actor was is
sort of the broader aspect of it or is
it mostly the character and if there is
for you to be for you to have a cameo in
one of the other cities which one are
you cameoing in well obviously Italy you
know I mean and also I can I could I
could do it in both languages and you
could whip up a meal too that would be
your Alter Ego in the show
I was not aware that they were going to
take this and and have different have it
done in different countries I didn't
know that it was only when I started
shooting that I became aware of that and
I thought that's amazing how do you even
do that I still don't know how you do
that but yeah but they're doing it and I
think it's I think it's super exciting
you've played so many iconic characters
I mean sitting across from you is just
such a delight what about this
particular one what traits in him were
most delicious to you to play what I
like about him is that he's very funny
it's a real caustic and dark sense of
humor but he has a great admiration and
love for the people that he works with
and protecting them is crucial but the
ultimate
his ultimate goal is for Citadel to
to come back to life and Destroy
Manticore and help make any sacrifice
necessary for that to happen and he's a
very moral person how many twists and
turns will we see for him so many really
yeah did it blow your mind to
yeah
it's really cool wow wow yeah
whoever to trade us
is readying for something cataclysmic
my favorite line from this is when the
line Mason Kane tops by hot stuff that
he calls himself that so I would love
you for you to name each other using
sort of the same thing oh my God give
each other each other can we do
ourselves can we use hot stuff yeah
can I can I be a spy sure oh my God this
is like this is one of those questions
where you're on the spot your brain just
starts melting are we doing ourselves
I'm gonna do myself okay yeah dude this
is what this is this is the difference
between in front of camera talent and
behind camera Talent okay
slow and steady wait are you supposed to
go Anthony Russo the top producer top
producer slow and steady right and I'm
supposed to go Joe Russo
uh dad
um
I have no idea I'm gonna call you future
futurists because that's what you've
called
we have we do we do we'll take that
we'll take that yeah so give
one of you
especially in this business
kind where we're getting a series where
there's going to be spin-offs in
different cities using their native
language so how has being a futurist how
how have you sort of allowed yourself
uh free reign with this series how is it
sort of allowed you to do what you've
always wanted to do the compelling
element of this series was when Jen
salki runs Amazon Prime called us and
said listen I want to use the resources
and infrastructure at Amazon to empower
storytellers around the world and I
think we could come up with a narrative
that could be shared and we said that's
an incredible idea
storytelling is one of the last binding
elements that we have and the incredibly
divisive world
you know you mentioned futurists we like
looking forward we're fine with
disruption it's compelling to us right
uh because out of disruption become new
ideas right and maybe it opens doors
that uh that were closed before and
certainly you know
um you know everything can be improved
upon and I think Anthony are most
compelled by global storytelling because
uh you know we we're collaborators it's
all we've done for 30 years we have to
sit and talk to each other all day long
and collaborate uh um uh telling stories
we want to open that up it's fun for us
it's engaging for us it's inspiring for
us to work with voices from around the
world that are we're all feeding into
this story and creating it together it's
like this giant Mad Lib that we're all
working on I'm wondering if in in the
series Richard Madden's character loses
his memory
but he dreams about Priyanka which is
the most relatable thing I could imagine
if the two of you had your memories
wiped out from your careers who's the
person you think you would still dream
about
I'm I have to say my wife in the
business though not your family yes
okay yeah no we're keeping personal out
of it I will just say Priyanka
I dream about I actually dreamed about
Priyanka last night
it's like you know
you know I don't know why but the person
that popped into my head was Chris Evans
how could you not I really thought you
were going to say John Stamos oh really
yeah is there don't you have a thing
with John Stamos I mean look we met
Stamos years ago I don't know that I
have a thing with James Taylor you know
I love that have you ever dreamed about
him uh I don't know maybe the day I met
him I did and I have to say the reason
you probably brought up Evans is we have
spent more time on set I think that's
why Chris Evans and anyone else in the
business by like triple I think yeah
yeah making people across the world
jealous just by saying that
um I know in the gray man I talked to
you guys about the fact that the
beginning of each scene there was sort
of a sweeping shot across the city and
this one there's a spinning element
that's right so what was that decision
what went into that decision is that the
duality of people on the show exactly
the concept is is when are you right
side up and when are you upside down in
the show what's the truth right there's
a catchphrase we've been using that
everything you know is a lie and really
the show is an onion that just keeps
getting peeled back as you progress
through the episodes until whole thing
flips on its head so it's uh in that
regard it was a lot of fun to make uh it
informed that's that stylistic choice uh
and pay attention to when the camera is
upside down when it's right side up I'm
really really curious what the two of
you are thinking about the recent box
office just in the fact that you've
talked about streaming that being the
future and now we have like Super Mario
crushing it John Wick crushing it
obviously Avatar too what are your
thoughts about how is I mean it's an
exciting time well sometimes I think
it's important like sometimes we get
characterized as like having a bias
towards streaming like we we love
everything we value every form of
expression for storytelling right so
we've like the box office is an amazing
opportunity we've had fantastic
experiences through the box office yes
you know so it's an amazing way to
communicate with audiences but so is
streaming we you know our Point has
always been
consider the opportunities the unique
opportunities that streaming offers I
was thinking about the fact that I think
you've
used films right saying if you keep
making films like this you won't work
and now I feel like tell me how this
series you've kept that I feel like
you've kept that advice stuck in your
head because everything you do you
almost up the ante how is this series
upping the Annie and how is this sort of
taking that advice into account and
moving in well the scale is certainly up
in the ante you know it's a it's
cinematic scale but it's also global
scale and we're D you know we're working
with
writers from other countries who are
working on shows at the same time
they're all based around the same
mythology
the coolest thing I think we've ever
done in the business was we had a
citadel Summit where the team from India
and the team from Italy came to the U.S
at our offices at agbo and we all worked
together for two days breaking story and
talking about the world and going
through the level of detail around the
world and you know it was it was the
most inspiring thing we've done I mean
this show this show has every two weeks
the show does a virtual writer's room
that includes
the the various creative teams around
the world talking about where they're at
how they're working with the characters
um and it's so it's a it's a unique
experiment in storytelling and that's
the heart of what the ambition here is
everything you know
is a lie
first wanted to ask you just in the fact
that this is the first time that anybody
has ever done a flagship show and then
there's going to be spin-offs different
languages around the world and Joan
Anthony were telling me that you're
having these sort of bi-weekly Zoom
meetings with other iterations so how
has producers showrunner how is that how
does that affect how you create a show
and how you put it together how much
more complicated is it from other things
you've done it actually makes it easy
does it yeah yeah and also better
because you have many different
perspectives coming to the table and
making ideas stronger and stronger and I
think that's been a real gift if
anything it's been incredible and their
their biases as you know American
storytellers I think that blind spots
that we have and so when we have a truly
Global writer's room every other week uh
you know our incredible Partners raise
questions or ask questions and it's just
been an amazing sort of learning process
for us for them and so collaboration is
key on this series and in everything but
um but I think it's it's helped us make
something immensely authentic yeah now
it's made me want to ask you what do
they point out to you or what do they
maybe because they are different if it's
a reflection or a mirror what you
realize about yourselves as American
storytellers that's maybe different from
the other series you're grinning
that's a very good question
um I I think there's just like an
egocentric you know
sort of bent sometimes
the hero you know and so I think it's
just about uh being able to see
ourselves you know or American spies for
example from the perspective uh from of
the rest of the world and and I think
that's been very helpful to create
characters who are richly complex who
have villainous sides to them who have
heroic sides to them who really live in
the gray
um so that's been really I think quite
quite exciting I think you know as in
series is
it truly inhabits the same amount of
space as the others it's just the
introduction really and each Series has
the best of the best from each country
coming to the table and delivering at
the same level of execution and ambition
and so that's been really remarkable
because I think you know to David's
Point usually it's Hollywood is you know
bigger and you know
um sort of serves as like the central
component that's not the case at all
here and that's really refreshing
speaking of bigger was there a sequence
there's I've only seen the first three
episodes it leaves me on such a gorgeous
Cliffhanger that I need the fourth
episode but is there a sequence that you
never thought you'd be able to get made
and you did and that you're like oh yeah
oh my God every sequence in the show is
a mess yeah it really is but I think I
think do you know what I don't think we
ever thought we would never get it made
just because the teams that we are
working with are truly the best of the
best and so you know they can pull it
off but I think the one we are most
excited to see manifest you know from
the page was a train yeah yeah I want to
take it on that train it's the most
gorgeous terrain beautiful isn't it I
was telling her she nailed that slow-mo
walk it's like nobody else could have
done that by the way in the red dress
kind of thing yes yeah you're like yes
it's so true yeah but also something
that really works for this with it
within the show it is epic and it is at
the scale but for you as producers
showrunner how was it to see because
they have such great chemistry like the
two of them was that something that you
felt from the get-go they had or did you
see it build as they got to know each
other
um because sometimes it's lightning in a
bottle you either do have it or you
don't well it is lightning in a bottle
and this is a real Testament to them not
only is it two actors coming together
playing a character and finding that
chemistry they are each about 50
different versions of themselves
throughout the course of this series so
they're coming into each scene you you
know like possessing only a certain
amount of knowledge or having you know
the full spectrum of knowledge in other
instances and so like to watch them sort
of maneuver through that and still find
that electricity but like modulating you
know to the right levels at the right
times was really exciting so true yeah
and there was no chemistry reads like we
no we got very lucky yeah very very
lucky yeah but their chemistry is so
palpable like if you feel it we sit at
video Village it was like oh my I know
they have been in love for all these
years you know it's amazing and those I
think the show hinges on it truthfully
it does if you didn't have that it
wouldn't work totally
um not that you need inspiration but
were there influences from other spy at
films of the past series of the past
um that you sort of
used as inspiration but look to that
sort of informed maybe either how you
wanted to do something or how you wanted
to do something that hasn't been done
before it was both yeah very much you
know of course there's like
nods to bond and Mission Impossible and
born but then at the same time and and
probably what was most exciting to us
was the opportunity to turn the
conventions on their head and present
something we haven't seen and so you
know when you talk about Richard and
Priyanka for example this series
revolves around a Duo and it's a Duo
that truly complements each other and
makes the other person even stronger and
better and they operate as a singular
unit in a lot of ways and so that's
really exciting and then on top of that
you have a woman you know as as one of
them and a diverse woman and then also
on top of that you have a dynamic that
exists between them for you know a
majority of the episodes that that you
watched where our female character you
know is taking a bit of a lead in a way
that we don't get to see and I found
that particularly exciting so when you
say you wanted to do something new in a
sense how would you describe it like how
would you describe the vibe of the show
maybe compared to other series or films
that we've seen in this genre before oh
I I think it's sort of an homage in
certain ways but we're in on the joke
you know in that I love that I think we
like to defy those conventions of the
Spy genre and really turn them on their
head uh so that is the thing about
Citadel as you said you know the great
Cliffhanger at the end of episode three
you never know what to expect with this
series so we come into it as fans and
lovers of the Spy genre but we want to
do something new and fresh and really
modern here who wrote the line hot stuff
that feels quintessential but it also
feels like it feels like maybe something
from the 80s or 90s but also let's bring
it back in 2023 and I love it
too it was really yeah
where did that come from oh God some
some recess of this I don't know I don't
know
so of I'm going to ask a really junk any
question but of I would say Joan Anthony
yeah and the entire cast who would make
the Best Buy in life who was sort of the
most observant and great question oh
totally totally because you can travel
there was that
um Topol who who played like Tavian
Fiddler on the Roof yeah they just
revealed he was like a massage spy for
many years so I always feel like actors
like it's the Julia Child thing too I
feel like coochie's got that going he
speaks many languages I think I also
think Leslie even though she's not a spy
in this series like she's unflappable
yes
very cool and yes like a rock yeah